あった
いっ
はせめて過分なよ
ええええええ
ああああああ
って
母が動い姫
皆さん気付かないと思うんですけども普段皆さんスナイパーに狙われてるんですよ
でスナイパーてパ一を狙うじゃなきゃいけないからどこにいるか分からない女
スナイパーをイメージしたガサガサでました
中野この顔ダンススナイパーブロックりスナイパーん最後の hg の命をこうなんか
マン
ホール前ででから狙うスナイパーイヤホンの紐にどさくさに紛れて狙わせないか
でも最近の人って少ないかに狙われて恐怖を忘れかけてるんじゃないかなと思いますね
今からターゲットはこのように来るんですけども
この子達をうまいことを隠してターゲットスナイパー42を全部見つけるまで
打たれ続けるドッキリをしようと思いますレバ確していこう
まずはイヤホンですイヤホンは多分僕の家結構どこにでも置いてあるねえ
全然こういう感じで入っても大丈夫な気がしますねここに置いておきましょう
パッと見完全にイヤホンで続いてサイコロなんかこういう小物がご座はたしている
ところに会っても気づかれない気がしますね
人に他の財布等も置いとけばこれわかるかなたぶん生まれないと思います今太郎に完成
品ものを買ってきました
こんなこのピンクだけも買っちゃえばいいんじゃ寝るもんなんかほとんど一緒な気が
すんだよ
[音楽]
まあね俺が貼るんでしょこのブロックポリーをスナイパーネストプリピチャいけ
いやーちょっと分かりやすいかなぁいやご覧になっていただきました
b
ええええええ
[音楽]
dee
すべて無スナイパーを設置しましたこれから直ちに
ターゲットこの辺に呼び込みますさあ
かもよ
[音楽]
私ましたそうです
疲れましたけどむしろ好かん
は9着だったていましたああ
[音楽]
3本目
ん
[音楽]
car
日本
このヘアースナイパーに狙われてますねこれ完全にスナイパーに狙われません
美味しいですん
をどこに入れた4人のスナイパー嬉しいです
4人もスター
ええええええ
car
はい秘密会を知りましょうん
[音楽]
これじゃあこれ白か違いますん
ダイバーですん
me
非常に4人いるらしい非常に
4銀一すよねこのといいですよねこの部屋の中に
今回4人の人がサイバーが
持っています
ています
car
会社へだ
やばいん
読みますよねます本年は以下いいん
ん
4時にはちゃんとんにいうふうに思います
あった
th
配置ないぞ使用者はウニっ
にもいい
[音楽]
rere ハロプロで実寸をはしておりません
j ございますよ
まず亜土さんに言うらしいですね
とさんですこのオフィスさみっていう左ゲイバーサーバっ1人語り
いったっ初のギター
これだっ
皆さんよしよしです順調
いい
うーんまん
いいところっ
持った
ああありがとうございます
水が凍るがすべてをスナイパーはついに見つけましたよ
4つあー
ああああああああ
今までありがとうございましたん
[音楽]
me
うううう
あっはぁ